hey guys and welcome back to grizzly
Valley this is the first out of two
episodes in which I'll try to finish
this rollercoaster which I never
expected myself to say and I actually
haven't finished the second episode yet
but I'll try to add all of the rockwork
and scenery and all of the detailing to
this rollercoaster in this episode and
the next one and in this one I will
focus on these facades over here some
other scenery around the mountain just
to make sure that it blends with the
environment around it as well and in the
next episode I'll try to finish the
mountain and get a castle on top of it
and also add some detailing to it
throughout and make sure that it's
entirely finished which I'm not sure if
I'm actually going to be able to do it
that quickly but if it is going to be
possible then I feel it would be quite a
good testament of how user-friendly I
think the building tools in the game are
so far one of my favorite parts of the
game is not that the building tools are
so so new or that they're very unique
but I think they're really user friendly
and you can very quickly create pretty
good buildings and nearly anybody I
think can make good buildings in this
game and it really doesn't take a lot of
practice to get used to it either and
that's really what I think is one of the
strong points of this game so it doesn't
take a lot of time to sort of translate
your ideas into what you want to build
in the game which i think is really good
and hopefully it should be able to make
this entire thing happen in two episodes
but I'm really not sure that because I
haven't really finished it so I'm just
crossing my fingers there anyway this
was sad here is what I figured it would
be a really good way to form an entrance
point to this area since coming from the
rest of the park that is the entrance
this is sort of one Square where all the
paths that is the two paths to what this
mountain meets and from both paths
you'll also be able to see the mountain
in the distance and I really felt that
it would be nice to also have a facade
in front of that so you got that sort of
layering effect so having the facade in
the front and then far away in the
background have the castle which also
helps with force perspective because the
console is going to be pretty small and
it's not going to be anything
spectacular
but much like the disney castles by
having it far away and having some
things in front of it and having it very
high on some rocky thing you can make a
building look much larger than it really
is
and that's really the idea of how i
wanted to lay out this area so when you
get to this little square and you have
these buildings in front of here it's
hopefully going to be somewhat
impressive like with the castle in the
background also something which i really
wanted to do here is get all of this
layering going on of different things so
there are paths going over paths and
different heights of paths but also the
coaster tracks going underneath paths of
this world over them which really i
think creates quite a dynamic area over
here and especially from the coaster POV
hopefully is going to look pretty good
in the end and aside from that the rocks
just work really nicely to blend
everything together since obviously
there is no terraforming yet and so this
all has to be done with rocks which is
going to take quite some time and
definitely going to be the most
time-consuming thing of this entire well
build over here but it's actually quite
a lot of fun and it's not too hard to
actually get the rocks in actually fine
you can pretty much stay with one Rock
almost as long as every time you place a
new Rock you slightly rotate it they
never really end up looking too much the
same this over here by the way is
finally the first shop to this entire
area one of the things which I do have
to say is that I'm probably still a bit
too used to how I do things in
roller-coaster kanthri given the
thousands of hours that I put into it
so I just keep forgetting to actually
add these shops and make use of them so
figured well I'm gonna have to do it
over here so there's just one small
premium food shop but I'll definitely
try and get some more shops and toilets
everybody loves toilets in this game and
the reddit has been petitioned to be
renamed to blender toilet so I might
want to put some effort into toilets as
well but I'll try that eventually the
main goal of this facade isn't really to
be anything functional but just as more
of a scenery and scenery type thing and
to really set the mood of
the Alpine theme which I have around
here and just because I felt like it
would be nice I wanted to add that
building in the back doesn't really
serve a function either but I figure it
would be nicer to have that at the back
of it and just Rock work because just
Rock work alone can get pretty boring
from the coaster POV standpoint
something which I should mention by the
way over here since it's currently
nighttime I decided that I'm going to
turn off the day and night cycle I did
get very mixed comments like some people
didn't want it at all but some people
actually liked it but I'm sorry for both
parties in some some kind of strange
fashion since I'm not going to use the
cycle anymore but I also won't keep it
day I think it's best to just determine
what looks best but especially what just
works best for what I'm trying to do so
in any case if I'm trying to add
lighting to a certain area I'll try to
do that at nights and if I'm trying to
build things especially the rockwork
since it's already quite dark and hard
to see at night I'll just do that a day
and aside from that I'll just leave the
day/night cycle alone the main reason
why I think is because as good as I
think both day and night look and as
handy as it is to have the cycle just to
make sure that you know what your
buildings and areas look like in
different Lighting's in different times
of day I think it's just too distracting
for the time-lapse especially how fast
the day/night cycle was and how pretty
distracting it was in the time-lapse
after all now this is going to be the
way that I'll try to make the mountain
by the way it's in a way it's quite
realistic it's gonna be just completely
a hollow mountain and I'll try to make
the surface with just rocks which is
going to take quite a bit of time and
it's probably going to be the most
time-consuming part of this entire
mission here but that's basically the
idea just filled up all up with rocks
and try to just for some variation
because the rocks alone look way too
bare add some simple foliage here and
there on the rocks but I'm not going to
over foliage it so it's not going to be
bare but it's not going to be an entire
forest either and trying to find the
middle ground there and I'm also
actually taking a lot of inspiration
from the the very old coaster is
actually from strata lesson roller
coaster [ __ ] 3 which is one of the best
builders in that game by the way and if
you're into roller coaster going through
you should totally check his stuff out
but he quite often did make these
terrain conforming and rocky coasters
which i think is a lot of fun to do and
with this coaster like many of his
projects I don't just want to focus on
their work work and make sure that the
coaster interact a lot with rock work
but also have some buildings here in
there so there's going to be the castle
on top of it and some buildings on the
sides of the mountain as well where the
coaster can go through the buildings or
have some wooden construction on the
side like these I'm not entirely sure
what they're called you have these
protection avalanche wooden fences on
the sides of mountains which are meant
to stop avalanches and that's something
which I would also like to try and have
some coaster interaction with because
I'm basically just looking for different
things not just rocks but also buildings
and other structures with which the
coaster can just interact and generally
the more things that the coaster can go
through and come very close to and
Moorhead shoppers you can get the more
exciting in the bud is going to be in
general not just in terms of how it
works in calculation but also how it
really works in real life and I think it
should eventually and are pretty nice
that way yeah in general the coaster
really draws from the very large
downward curves of Expedition Everest or
as well as that mountain theme where it
sort of has the interaction with the
castle on top of it which is very trips
trail like and well it's probably very
similar as well to many of the mountain
rides that Disney and Fantasy Island
have so there's a lot of real-life
inspiration even though the roller
coaster might not be that realistic
especially trike why since bnm would
never realistically make a coaster like
this
imagine that it's a mine train coaster I
suppose which yeah I do realize that the
arrow
Rek is a lot more realistic after all
than the bnm track but I think the
blue-collar
just suits it a little bit more than the
very vibrant red now this building over
here is just pretty much the same as
actually the cue building which I built
in the first episode in terms of basic
structure but I really wanted to have
that small Alpine house on top of it
which is very similar again to the
houses which I made in the facade
earlier in this episode and they're all
part of a more Austrian style Alpine I
would say especially with the roofs
which really hang over and the very
large balconies which I'm actually
really happy about that it actually
worked out and the basic style is really
just down to that you have a roof which
really sticks out from the walls and
balconies and go from there pretty much
I do want to work more with different
types of timber frames since I don't
really have any wooden frames in this
building yet and that's something which
I still want to return to in the future
but just for a cue I think it'll do
since it really doesn't have to be too
much now from this point onwards this
episode is only going to be about the
rockwork which is quite a necessary evil
in this case or this may actually be a
praise of a pretty trivial thing of the
game but I don't think the rock work is
actually that evil in this game it's one
of the things which I also really love
about this game
and I'll explain why exactly because
even though they're really small rocks
and there's a very small variety they're
actually very versatile especially
thanks to and the placement of course
and how you can freely rotate them and
especially in this case I'm using the
most right rock really because I feel
it's the it's the largest rock so that
means it's job postures done but it also
has like very different parts of the
rock like some more rugged parts and
some smoother parts so you can really
use them like this rock this one Rock is
almost this entire Mountain and yet the
mountain really looks like it's made out
of unique rocks and doesn't really look
too repetitive at all and also something
which I really like about the rocks but
this comes down more to a theme-park
realism aspect is the fact that it
actually does look like quite a natural
rock if it
to be but it actually resembles the
theme-park rocks quite a bit as well
since theme parks obviously use fake
rocks which is actually a common problem
in roller coaster country is that all
the rocks look too realistic to actually
make coasters out of them or make
coasters with them like Thunder Mountain
since those are really fake rocks but
the rocks actually look pretty fake ish
or quite similar to them if you want to
and actually very flexible in terms of
how entirely you shape areas and of
course the textures are just really
awesome and they work really well with
the lighting and the shadows on them are
really beautiful so that's why I
actually had quite a bit of fun to make
this Rock work here but yeah in this
episode I'll pretty much finish the rock
work nearly except for the very end of
the mountain but get the top done
regardless so in the next episode I'll
be able to write from the starts start
building the castle and also add details
to this rock work another thing with
which was actually quite handy in this
case is that there is actually the
clearance on the rocks which you can see
them turn red all the time you can't
place rocks exactly next to the track
which made actually my job quite a bit
easier since I didn't really have to pay
attention to rocks going through the
track because they just can't but aside
from that's having no clearance on the
rocks themselves is really handy and the
way they blend together is just really
amazing still though I want the rocks to
actually be very close to the track
especially underneath the track since
realistically mine train comes parts of
this coaster would be next to the ground
to be able to have the track BET's run
on the ground which even though this
isn't a mind training coaster I still
wanted to have it run as close to the
rocks as it could but also very much on
the side and on top of the tracks I will
actually keep the rocks very close to
the track with just almost misses but
not quite hitting the tracks yet just
because I I think it would be a lot
nicer and also this coaster has quite a
bit of speed and just by having those
rocks really closer to track everything
seems to like whiz by much faster than
if you were just out in the middle of
and that's basically religious the plan
of this entire mountain of the rocks go
right past the tracks here and then in
the end shape up the mountain to look
more like an actual mountain in the
shape and in the end put a castle on top
of it and some more details and make
that one hell of a ride that's basically
the idea behind all of it and also in
terms of Walt Disney this is going to be
sort of the one we knee of the park so
this is going to be just the one eye
catcher and the highest point probably
in the park and really what I sort of
want everything to go towards so this
entire career and the castle on top of
it should really be visible from the
largest area around this and probably is
going to be sort of the major and main
attraction of this park much like you
can see thunder mountain or Expedition
Everest from very far away as well and
they're really these very huge eye
catching attractions and that is still
the idea behind this the only thing it
really lacks probably is a basketball
court in the middle of it which I think
actually Expedition Everest had but not
anymore probably anyway that's massively
off top as I think the have launch
things are called snow fences but yeah
anyway that's just about it for this
episode just a couple more works the
place but I'm pretty much going to head
back in to planet coaster again and try
to work on the third episode and see if
I can get that done hopefully by today
and upload that time sometime soon as
well so yeah thank you guys for watching
and see you guys in the next episode in
which I'll start it off with the castle
on top of this mountain here